I I even think in a relationship
honestly if he's not sleeping with
anyone else yeah you should give him sex
whenever he wants whatever he wants yeah
she's like why should he go get it
on the [__] all the time so if I'm
saying like please don't [__] other
girls just [__] me like then I should I
should get back here
okay wait I understand that but then if
there's just a one day where it's like
I'm not in it right now or I'm on my or
whatever you're not you know
does that mean that he now has a right
to go and have sex with someone
obviously he's not one day
that's what I'm saying but you guys are
making it sound I'll give you one day
not too I'll give you one day Matthew
if you miss work one day they might give
you a passive two days in a row